dad you can't talk to Jerry that
way anymore we're a real family now in
many ways things will be like season 1
but more streamlined now Jerry and I are
happily married parents and the idea
that I was motivated by a fear of you
leaving can be a shoot eschewed you've
never used that word maybe you are a
clone not like Rick would tell us holy
crap everybody so that was a Rick and
Morty finale I think the biggest
surprise is wondering whether or not
Beth was still a clone and why they
chose this episode in particular to be
the finale in not episode 7 which was
more like a big mythology episode so
we'll try to address that after I do
Easter eggs but I'm also gonna do a
season 4 video and I'll explain what my
weekly bonus video schedule is gonna be
for Rick and Morty now that we're in the
off season and when I think that season
4 is actually gonna get here so be sure
to subscribe to get everything if you're
just finding me for the first time
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video - so obviously this is Rick
versus the United States president
that's all it really ended up being
there was a small name drop for evil
Morty but he was really only referenced
he didn't physically appear in the
episode neither did Tammy the Federation
Phoenix person any of that big stuff so
obviously they're all leaving that for
season 4 the title of the episode the
rectory and Morty Tate is a reference to
the movie The Manchurian Candidate but
is also a bit of a gravity falls Easter
Egg the stanchion candidate even though
the plot of both of those episodes is a
little bit different but it seems like
they were only using the episode to wrap
up the divorce storyline like basically
reset everyone back to season 1 as Beth
breaks the fourth wall at the end of the
episode
I guess she knows that she's inside a
television show now - but the whole
president story was kind of like a bad
breakup that Rick then later reset when
he pretended to be fly-fishing Rick so
when they opened the episode they sort
of used the 24 digital clock text at the
bottom they don't use the 24 transitions
sound though Rick burns the hell out of
people that play minecraft then kind of
burns himself like he's I'd autistic
people play this because I'm really
loving it so I guess Rick is saying that
he's autistic when he breaks the fourth
wall again
that South Park did it four years ago
he's talking about the episode where
they do that how do you tame a horse in
Minecraft where they put child lock on
everybody's TVs they have that joke
about them flying the helicopter all the
way to their house when Rick can travel
anywhere he wants in an instant because
there's always TV shows where people
wonder how characters get around so
quickly like how did he get here if he
was just over here on the other side of
the earth so they said that several
times of the episode don't you realize
that Rick could teleport everywhere he
can travel anywhere he wants the janitor
that the googas kill at the beginning of
the episode is drawn to look exactly
like one of the writers of the episode
Mike may had he appears in some of those
behind the scenes features that they do
most of you probably know that the
googas was an old channel 101 skit that
Dan Harmon and Justin roiland did a long
time ago almost 10 years ago I talked a
little bit about it last week right they
think of themselves as ghostbusters the
device that Morty's using to detect the
googas looks exactly like the device
they used to detect ghosts in that first
Ghostbusters movie there were a whole
bunch of special underground rooms in
the White House so if you were a
conspiracy theorist about the government
this episode is probably like candy to
you because there are so many things
that they imply about our nation's
history and some of our most famous
presidents so there's the kennedy sex
tunnels the truman cocaine lounge the
McKinley hooker dump in the Lincoln
slave Coliseum later in the episode when
they're fighting each other they crash
through most of those rooms but I don't
think we ever make it to the slave
Coliseum but there's a bunch of extra
stuff that you spot in there like when
they crash into the Truman cocaine
lounge there's a bowl of cocaine just
waiting to go in case anybody happens in
and he throws it at Rick so I guess Rick
is super high by the end of the episode
but if you remember toxic rick versus
rick going around their house just
grabbing all kinds of hidden secret
weapons that's kind of the thing that
they have going here there's all kinds
of hidden weapons all over the White
House that he tries to take Rick down
with when I saw these kids pop out at
first I thought they were
the kids from the shining but they
actually look a little more like the
kids from escape to Witch Mountain which
is basically just two little kids with
psionic abilities so then when they
crash through the McKinley hooker dump
you spot a bunch of fake news sets that
looks like they filmed and faked the
moon landing along with the Kennedy
assassination 911 that's actually a
pretty big one and there was actually
the callback to Episode one where Rick
is watching that and starts to think
that it's an inside job along with the
jungle set and Washington Crossing the
Delaware so it's like they're saying
that a lot of our nation's biggest most
WTF events were all completely faked
there's even a UFO said too but they do
say that there's an area 51 where
they're keeping poseidon locked up a
living god that won't submit so there's
a lot of contradictory things like they
do have a lot of fantastic stuff but a
lot of the real-life fantastic stuff
that America has supposedly done was I
guess fate based on what brick and Morty
is saying so like I said if you really
love government conspiracy theories this
is your episode but jumping over to the
Beth's storyline so this is like the big
question after the episode is she really
a clone in the way they left it they're
like well we'd never really tell you if
she was she asserts herself as a clone a
couple times in the episode but I think
the real clue is in that first
conversation she's having with him when
he says wait a minute you're not just
pretending to believe me when I say that
you're not a clone because I would have
to terminate you if you became
self-aware
so that really just means that they're
both lying to each other but I think
that Rick's reaction to her at the end
of the episode when he comes to the
cabin says it all he says Beth you're my
daughter and you have to remember that
Rick is c-137 Rick but he's jumped into
several different bodies over the course
of the season just season 3 so even in
last week's episode he told the original
Beth from this reality you're not my
Beth but all Rick's love they're Beth's
so ultimately it doesn't matter if her
consciousness is in a different body
he's going to love the clone just like
it were the real Beth so he's going to
treat her the same way which means that
he won't kill her so he's kind of stuck
with the family because clone Beth
actually does love Jerry and that's one
of the other times the
Beth is like yeah I'm basically a clone
because I'm not the real Beth because I
love you and there's even all that
weirdness with summer like she's super
cool with her having sex if the results
are too strong make sure you use
protection
any time a big character like that goes
through a 180 overnight you just had to
be suspicious about stuff like that but
hopefully that answers the question
about clone Beth like she's going to be
treated like original Beth from this
reality and she's effectively the exact
same thing and by the end of the episode
when she says Rick would never tell us
otherwise so it's sort of their way of
saying that they're never definitively
going to say yes this is a clone no this
is original Beth like you just left to
wonder even though I think all the clues
are there she's a clone it's just that
they're never gonna call her out as that
you probably picked up on Dan Harmon's
voice too when they were at the crappy
mall like they get really meta with
those subtitles
whoever's typing them when they go to
the different locations I guess really
hates this malted type crappy mall then
it's Dan Harmon's voice on that PA there
were a whole bunch of Easter eggs when
they went to see that tiny civilization
the people that found them in the hazmat
suits call them elgu Gatos which I guess
is their version of Google and Spanish
but Rick and the president go back and
forth they make a couple movie
references shrinking 70 style is a
fantastic voyage reference this is she a
60s movie so they're a little off on the
decade but the pills and the ship look
like they're right out of Fantastic
Voyage and inner space then when they
make the joke about growing like you're
in a 50s movie that's attack of the
50-foot woman there's a whole bunch of
visual gags like he's wearing a top with
no bottom so you basically have naked
president Keith David for a large
portion of the episode like he just
walks with his bits swinging around in
the wind we learned that Rick is afraid
of pirates and the government apparently
gets all of its information about him
from his Wikipedia page but Rick fixes
Israel and Palestine by getting them
super high and taking them to a Star
Wars Cantina then there's a big
conspiracy tear where Rick calls himself
out and he's sort of calling out
conspiracy theorists too when he says
I'm Doctor Who and this mother I could
be a hologram I could be a clone I could
be a clone being controlled with a
headset evil Morty style buy the real
Rick and Morty that are having
sex with your mother so that's sort of
your evil Morty wink like being
controlled with a headset by another
version of Rick and Morty so that's
about as close as we get to evil Morty
in the episode people thought that this
was them taking a swipe at conspiracy
theorists but they're also working in
some real things from Rick and Morty
like they've actually done some of these
things and I forget who you are but
somebody in my timeline said that on the
back of Jerry's rope here are the
Chinese characters for a week we just is
totally appropriate for Jerry's
character but I don't know why he would
wear a robe that actually said a week
maybe that's just Jerry being stupid not
realizing what's going on but if there
was any confusion fly-fishing Rick at
the end of the episode is our Rick
pretending to be fly-fishing Rick so
that he can stay on this reality and
sort of reset his relationship with the
president because before he has it out
with his family he's intending to go
somewhere else but there are a couple of
times in the episode where he says it's
a real to go to a different
reality that's the writers saying that
we're not just gonna like wash our hands
of this storyline and jump to another
reality and reset all this character
development that's happened this season
so Morty's gotten a little bit smarter
more assertive so the title of the
episode seems like it's more of a
reference to that morty being controlled
by Rick most of this season and then
Morty sort of shaking off that control
and also based on what Rick says to
Jerry at the end of the episode it seems
like he's his true nemesis now like when
they say arch-nemesis in the episode
Jerry is the ultimate villain for Rick
that he'll never be able to take down
even though you have other people like
evil Morty swirling in the background
that seemed like more traditional
villains like Jerry beats Rick the
things that you never thought would be
able to happen he's this cancer that
they can't get rid of hijacking his
family so Rick is stuck with them and
that's why he's so pissed off at the end
of the episode so sort of my final
judgement is that it was actually a good
episode of Rick and Morty but is a
finale it was kind of weak like you
hoped that they'd build up to something
a little bit bigger so like episode 7
probably would have been a better finale
but they would have had to wrap up the
divorce storyline so you can kind of see
how they structured things because a lot
of this stuff that they did with the
divorce wouldn't have worked in episode
7 so it's a little bit messy but like
they say they're resetting things to
more of a season 1
style so we'll see what season four
looks like but as for the mr. poopy
butthole post-credit scene that was them
sort of calling out the fans like hey
just don't sit around and do nothing
waiting for season 4 to get here but you
do see the pictures in the background so
I guess this mr. poopy butthole actually
did have adventures in these past couple
of years with this version of the family
but again it's just a riff on the
post-credits scene from season 2 and I
think he was a little more specific in
that version of the scene this time
they're a little more general like it's
gonna be a long time before season 4
gets here but I'll talk a little bit
about that when I post my season 4 video
that'll be tomorrow but let me know in
the comments if you spotted any other
references that I didn't mention in the
episode and let me know what you thought
of it in general I know it's gonna be
very divisive but there's a new round of
the merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video congratulations to the
last winner Brill Chan please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for more Easter eggs and
you can click here for brand new flash
season 4 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]